[Music]
welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news coming out of afghanistan
where there's been an explosion outside
kabul international airport it happened
around about half an hour ago our
correspondent at the time charlotte
bella said that the team at al jazeera
in the capital heard an explosion
somewhere in the vicinity of the airport
now we're trying to get more
clarification as to where that explosion
happened some reports are suggesting it
was inside samar suggesting outside
john kirby who's a spokesperson for the
pentagon in the u.s says and we quote we
can confirm an explosion outside kabul
airport casualties are unclear at this
time we will provide additional details
when we can well for
most of the day we've been of course
talking to our correspondents about the
warnings being given by the u.s and nato
allies as the evacuation continues as
they try to get their staff and
associates out of the country there were
strong indications even according to the
taliban that
such an imminent attack was uh pending
uh some were pointing the fingers at
isil and we've been discussing whether
isil had the capability of performing uh
such an act and if so when and where uh
it seems that uh over several days uh
the taliban have also been concerned
about uh isil infiltration into the
capital kabul and of course uh it you
might say has been a prime target for
anybody that might want to disrupt those
operations thousands of people have been
trying to
leave the airport as the 31st of august
deadline uh continues uh and of course
uh where nato and the u.s are planning
to take as many people out as they can
that have helped them through this
20-year process of trying to nation
build in a country that seems to now uh
as we've seen in this last two weeks
been taken over
by the taliban
in the past 24 hours uh the taliban made
it very clear that only those that were
either american or international
passport holders or had the appropriate
visas to leave the country would be
allowed to do so
anybody else that didn't have the
appropriate paperwork has been pushed
back from the airport of course the
scenes that you're seeing now are of
what what 24 hours ago when many people
were hoping that they may be able to get
into
the perimeter of the airport facility
and try to plead their case and get on
as many of these flights that were
heading either
up north into the central asian
republics and uh passengers being
diverted there into europe and north
america or via the middle east and the
horn of africa as we're hearing uh some
afghans already arrived in uganda and in
qatar where they are now being
repatriated via domestic flights into
the u.s
the issue
of whether this was
any sort of attack has yet to be
determined no one has taken
responsibility
let's join rob mcbride our correspondent
in the capital uh of kabul rob these
details very sketchy we have an idea
from the pentagon that an explosion has
occurred
what did you hear or what did what do we
know
about this explosion
well this happened a little under one
hour ago
and it was colleagues of ours in the
bureau which is a couple of kilometers
from where we are here closer to the
airport actually heard it there uh other
that's been confirmed by other sources
as an explosion coming from the
direction
of the airport and then it has since
been confirmed uh by the pentagon that
they understand this is an explosion
that has gone off there's no mess
there's no word yet about uh any
casualties and it apparently uh happened
at one of the uh
one of the centers that's close to the
airport uh we understand it's one of the
encampments used by the contractors
different contractors have a different
bases around this the perimeter of the
airport it's apparently happened near to
one of theirs near to one of those
encampments now we're waiting to see get
confirmation that it is an explosion but
it comes at the end of a day of
heightened tensions all around the
airport with these warnings of an
imminent attack a suicide attack from
multiple sources by islamic state or at
least the afghan offshoot of that
organization now islamic state has been
active here in afghanistan they tried to
establish themselves especially since
the demise of is in other parts in the
parts of the middle east they tried to
take root here that was fought back
against by the military the government
and also with the support of the united
states and in fact there was a real
there was a real concerted effort by the
led by the united states to try to drive
them out of afghanistan it resulted in a
lot of serious attacks in 2019 which
seriously diminished their ability but
we know that they have still been active
especially in the east of the country
with these small units they have been
carrying out small attacks especially in
kabul and especially on some targets
that the taliban wouldn't uh wouldn't
attack targets that they deem to be
justifiable justifiable so they have
been threatening to carry out some sort
of attack as this evacuation has
continued we know that they tend to
thrive upon disorder and chaos and with
everything that's going on at the
airport at the moment with the
evacuation with thousands of people
around there with
foreigners and people associated with
foreign missions trying to get to the
airport it is an extremely vulnerable
time
it is from an is point of view a prime
target so there have been these uh
threat these uh warnings that an attack
was imminent we had these warnings
earlier on in the week but they have
been really reinforced in the past 24
hours or so confirmed by multiple
sources and even the taliban themselves
saying yes there is likely to be an
attack and also warning that in fact
their taliban fighters are just as much
at risk as anybody else there at the
airport and of course rob there was
great concern in the lead up to you
might say the sweeping victory of the
taliban to take over the country the
various prisons and areas of
incarceration where isil operatives were
being held had been basically they've
been let loose the doors had been opened
but nobody had actually taken any note
of where these individuals were going so
the threat level was increased as soon
as those jails were opened
that's right and in fact there is one
prison close to the
backroom base bagram was the base that
was the home to u.s forces and also its
nato allies during the long-running
campaign here and there was a prison
quite close to there which housed a
number of isil prisoners now that prison
was opened and the gates were thrown
open as with many other prisons
throughout afghanistan it was and it was
assumed that a number of isil prisoners
could well have escaped then
they so
as as we said they have been responsible
for some uh pretty audacious uh uh uh
pretty despicable attacks as far as
western governments are concerned and
also the many people here in afghanistan
and the government is concerned uh such
as you know
attacking targets that the taliban would
not deem to be uh legitimate targets so
they have been responsible for uh some
quite serious attacks the taliban
relationship with them remains uh
somewhat ambiguous at times officially
the taliban says they have no dealings
with uh with uh with islamic state and
will not have any dealings under the new
administration with the islamic state
they've made that extremely clear and as
they've reiterated with these current
threats that their taliban fighters are
just as much as at risk as any soldiers
from the us or the other uh
or other coalition allies or
people thronging around the airport in
fact if anything taliban would meet more
in the front line they are more exposed
if you like to some sort of a suicide
attack by islamic state because of
course that would be on the outside of
the base it's very difficult to see that
they could ever penetrate the base and
get close to western soldiers so taliban
would be just as much at risk having
said that there have been some occasions
where the taliban has been uh
has there have been suspicions that
taliban at least at some local levels
have been working in coordination
with islamic state but as i said
on a national level the taliban says it
has nothing to do and will have nothing
to do with the islamic state group but
we are still waiting to see if this was
indeed
an attack an actual bombing at the
airport and indeed what casualties there
could be and of course uh various
contributors to al jazeera have said
that there's no love lost between isil
and the taliban but the real test of uh
the taliban's control over the country
is whether they can actually find out
where this group or various members of
this group are actually operating from
and whether they have the information
network in place as they'd like perhaps
the rest of the world to understand that
they have this in place right now
whether it is actually effective in
finding those that may be behind this
attack on the airport because it would
be a test of their authority
across the country
it will be extremely interesting to see
the relationship and the attitude of the
taliban now in government uh to uh to
islamic state you know as we as we've
said uh they've had a slightly ambiguous
relationship towards them in the past
the previous government as we said
made extraneous efforts to try to wipe
them out back in 2019 and very nearly uh
did so you would have thought if you
were islamic state you would be looking
with relish at what's happening the
withdrawal of u.s forces all of its
allies the collapse
of the ashraf ghani government and the
taliban coming into into force remember
of course that the taliban were
extremely uh
they made the point very strenuously a
few days ago in all of their first
briefings when they suddenly found that
they were the government here and they
were running the country that they would
not give any kind of haven to groups
that were intent on uh bringing the
fight to western governments that of
course was you know why the western
governments got involved all of those 20
years ago that's the big fear that
remains for the united states and its
allies and the taliban quite smartly
were very very quick to allay those
fears they saying that uh the new
afghanistan would not be a haven to any
groups such as presumably uh islamic
state but it will be interesting to see
what relationship they do have with
islamic state
will they be as robust as the previous
government in trying to wipe them out
and trying to push them out of
afghanistan
and from islamic state point of view
what will their relationship be with the
the taliban when we were considering the
possible attack on the airport remember
of course you've got taliban fighters
there
the thinking was that the islamic state
if they did launch an attack they would
want to be very careful that they target
certainly uh westerners or western
forces or any uh members of uh the us
military or its allies
it
would in the collateral damage
inevitably get passengers who or people
who are trying to get onto flights out
of the country but if you're islamic
state you could probably justify that in
as much as these people were effectively
from an islamic state point of view
almost collaborating with foreign
governments and if their collateral
damage then so be it but they would be
very careful islamic state not to
catch any taliban in the uh
as collateral damage because they would
know that if they want to stay in
afghanistan
despite all of the assurances from the
taliban that they're not going to give
safe haven to any of these groups they
really have to stay under the radar
especially in the early days early
months to see how this all plays out
with this new government coming into
power here
rob mcbride thanks very much uh rob
mcbride our correspondent let's cross
over to charlotte bellas who joins me
now on the phone from kabul um we
managed to get a gist of what you said
before charlotte about uh the lead-up to
this explosion just let me explain as
well that what we can see now our live
pictures are from kabul airport we can
still see helicopters landing and we can
still see planes taking off so the
operation at the airport seems to be
progressing
as normal but tell us what you know
well we're just leaving the scene now
actually and
uh
we heard ourselves in that explosion
about an hour ago we
got through as close as we could get to
the airport we understand it took place
uh at abbey gate that's what witnesses
are telling us that is one of the points
of entry for these evacuation flights
for people trying to get on them
usually it's crowded there's a lot of
people the taliban are outside that gate
and have been
been doing security around their area
but i've been down there in recent days
and americans have been overlooking that
area also
standing on the fence line so we
understand an explosion took place and
then there was heavy gunfire afterwards
when we looked down the street towards
it there was heavy smoke there were
hundreds of people fleeing towards us
and
and taliban fighters there were telling
us to leave immediately because there
was an explosion and an ongoing attack
a
colleague of mine spoke to someone who
was there he said that there were lots
of quote wounded and dead and he said
that americans were shooting it's quite
unclear at this moment who
may have set this explosion off
one taliban contact told me that they
believed that the americans were
destroying equipment at the time
but in contrast to that we understand
that the isil threat was quite high here
that's one of the reasons that many
countries said that they have stopped
their evacuations the americans also put
out an alert the taliban saying today
that no one can come near the airport
because the isil threat is high because
they are looking at doing specifically
car bombings in and around the airport
to inflict quote maximum damage as a
taliban contact told me today so whether
or not this is isil or something else is
still unclear but it looks like they
certainly are casualties from this
incident of course hard to predict the
future charlotte but if this is an
incident that has been perpetrated by
isil it seems that all sides will have
to uh decide and reconfigure their plans
perhaps about the 31st of august
yes i mean security the security
concerns have been growing here
we understand that for the most part
these evacuation flights are starting to
slow they were getting dozens off every
day and now
there's certainly fewer flights taking
off uh as they're kind of ramping down
and and now looking to uh get their
remaining military out who have been
facilitating this this operation uh but
i think
for the most part it's full steam ahead
on getting everyone out by the 31st the
taliban said it's certainly a red line
that no one can stay whether or not this
attack speeds things up it's hard to
tell of course we can see one military
uh plane taking off from the airport as
the sun sets across the afghan capital
it does beg the question about security
across the city
as well uh
in terms of
how much of the city the taliban can
control you i think either you spoke to
us earlier in the day or rob mcbride did
and said that more forces were being
brought into the capital from the
regions
the taliban have brought in all their
most elite forces even on day one they
brought in a thousand of their special
forces when they took over the city and
then they've been becoming they've
become increasingly organized as the
days have gone on around the airport
perimeter now they have
a unit known as the
badgery313s which are the
most elite special forces from the
taliban they're associated with haqqani
network and they had been in control of
the perimeter going down there just
yesterday i spoke with some of the
commanders
they were from different from different
areas but they were
trying their best to do crowd control
but it was very much a soft target and
you can see why
isil would target it because there were
thousands of civilians and the taliban
were fairly overwhelmed and their best
attempt to control and push people back
were shooting in the air they were
resorting to beating people uh we drove
through a cloud of tear gas at one point
it was chaotic and it has been and there
has been no improvement in the last 10
days
in the management of this
and there's been a lot of blame to go
around the taliban have said well we're
controlling security but why is this our
problem this is america's situation to
sort out they should have been more
organized and managing these people and
so and it seems like it's never really
been resolved there was a deal between
the taliban and the us as far as
security goes and who would manage what
but there's been so many loopholes every
side overwhelmed and everyone just
pushing as hard as they can to this
deadline to get as many people out and
then cut it and
the cards will fall as they as they lie
yeah charlotte let me just bring you up
to speed with what we're getting in
terms of wires uh we're getting a
turkish uh defense ministry uh quote
they're saying there were two explosions
outside kabul airport no damage to any
turkish units
and uh from the us we're getting three
of their troops have been injured
in the kabul blast but they can't tell
us exactly where they were injured so uh
the turkish and the americans confirming
uh certainly the blast and certainly
injuries as well injuries on one side
one has to assume there may be injuries
on the civilian side too
it's most certainly um to i mean if the
americans are saying that three of their
personnel were injured that doesn't
surprise me because when you go down to
the abbey gate to get in that way there
is a post overlooking the gate
where there's a number of us uh
soldiers stationed i watched them myself
the other day overlooking the crowds and
then just a few meters from them there
is a taliban checkpost and they watch
each other all day and then there's
dozens the other day when we were there
there were hundreds of civilians packed
like sardines banging at the gate hoping
for a chance to get in holding their
papers up to the americans so if there
has been an explosion in that vicinity
there are certainly americans posted
above that wall overlooking everything
and may have been caught up in this we
heard this explosion at 5 40 p.m local
time which is just over an hour ago when
we were there we heard a second
explosion
which was not as strong
and we also heard
sirens coming from inside the airport
and then the taliban had just pushed
everyone back and they had
appeared to have brought in
reinforcements they were
at least double the number of taliban
fighters down there guarding the
entrance as they normally were they were
very tense they were shooting in the air
i saw them break uh a camera from
another journalist
and
they were very tense and and very
concerned and shooting uh frequently
uh charlotte we're also getting more
news from the americans that they
suspect that this was a suicide attack
if that is the case then it does lead
into the direction of isil doesn't it
yeah isil's
mo if you will in kabul is to do
suicide blasts that target civilians
usually they target the shia minority
and they they have been
a constant threat in the back of
everyone's minds in kabul for some years
now although it has been some time since
they have
pulled off any type of
large attack
but they are very much uh
enemies with the taliban and that is one
thing that the west and the taliban have
had in common here is their mutual
hatred for isil and isil pockets have
been in the east of afghanistan but they
have tried to target civilians in in
previous years and and this was
definitely on everyone's radar that
it would be easy for them to target the
airport the the taliban tried to push
people back but there were just so many
people there was no way to check
people's bags to pad people down as they
entered the area uh because the airport
itself is is so big all they did was
shoot in the air and and it appears it
has not been enough
charlotte ballis uh in kabul thanks very
much uh for the update uh of course
we'll continue to monitor what goes on
these are live pictures coming from uh
kabul international airport of course
the sun is set it's early evening there
now uh it seems that the uh military
operations to get people evacuated from
the country continue and that the bomb
blasts that we've been hearing about
haven't um interrupted uh that sequence
of events however everybody will be on
alert let's just cross over to kimberly
halcott our white house correspondent in
the us of course the us just getting
that news now and kimberly we were
getting various uh sourced uh
information from the pentagon about what
they thought was behind these explosions
what are you hearing from them now
officially
well we should point out that the
pentagon is expected to brief and so we
are watching for the latest official
updates out of the pentagon and from the
department of defense spokesperson john
kirby but already the united states has
confirmed that they suspect this was a
suicide bomb and as we have been
reporting there are potential casualties
as well as injuries we know there are
injuries to at least three u.s service
members
the extent of those injuries is unclear
now here at the white house things are
changing very quickly i can tell you
that the u.s president joe biden has
been briefed on the explosion that has
occurred at kabul airport i can also
tell you that he already met with his
top national security advisers
and in some ways unfortunately this was
not unexpected in fact we know that the
u.s state department as well as other
american officials had been cautioning
americans we know there are at least
1500 that are still awaiting evacuation
they were told not to go to the airport
because of concerns of what has now
transpired and that is some sort of
explosion what we are told is that this
is potentially a suicide bomber that is
behind this detonation now
given the fact that there was a warning
in advance it's not clear how many
americans in addition to these service
members may potentially be affected by
this but again
this now begs the question about what is
next now the u.s president up until
today had been very firm about the
withdrawal of u.s troops to be completed
by august 31st but he said that with
that being contingent on the
continued evacuation of those that
needed to get out prior to that
withdrawal deadline
he also said that he was drawing up
contingency plans and had directed the
pentagon to do so but did not provide
any details so the question becomes
whether or not the president would now
be exploring whether to exercise some of
those contingency plans and what exactly
that means if there will be a
delay of the withdrawal date that's
something certainly that members of
congress and members of his own
democratic party have been urging as
well as the international community
these are the unanswered questions that
are now percolating here at the white
house we will have an opportunity to
hear from the u.s president he is
scheduled to meet with the israeli prime
minister naftali bennett that is coming
up at 15 30 gmt we've not yet had word
of whether or not that meeting will be
delayed we know that afghanistan was one
of the topics that would be discussed
it's very likely now that that will
become a primary topic of discussion and
of course some of these issues i've
raised are certain to be asked by the
reporters who will be present for the
initial part of that oval office meeting
uh just to bring you up to speed from
the wires that are dropping here from
reuters kimberly
no german troops injured in the
explosion outside the airport the turks
are saying they haven't been injured in
this though there were two explosions
obviously um one would assume that the
american president or those of the
pentagon will be speaking to their nato
partners that have military personnel at
the airport and they'll also be talking
if you if you're talking about these
contingency plans about how they are
going to work together in terms of
either the 31st of august or how to
re-evaluate the evacuation process
the pressure was already on joe biden to
extend this august 31st deadline to keep
american troops in country
for at least a period of extended time
to allow for the evacuations there's no
doubt that the pressure is going to be
even more intense for him to become more
flexible and potentially extend this
deadline not only has there been
domestic pressure on capitol hill but
also of course as he met earlier with
the g7 leaders they urged him to extend
this august 31st deadline so one can
presume that that coordination is taking
place we as mentioned i already know
that there was a meeting in the
situation room of the white house where
the top security officials of the united
states were briefing the president we
know since then he has been updated on
this explosion but again we should
remind our viewers that this is
something that the white house was
preparing for given the fact that there
had been indications and warnings that a
suicide bombing or a bombing of some
kind or disturbance of some kind could
take place at the kabul airport that is
why americans were told not to go to the
airport and that's why the evacuation
flights had slowed and there had been
some interruption in that effort that
the white house insists remains its
highest priority so these are questions
that are being raised we suspect at the
white house right now
the contingency plans
still not clear what those are only that
we can tell you the pentagon had been
directed to order those up and we're now
watching very carefully to see what the
defense department will say moving
forward there is a pentagon briefing
that is scheduled and there's no
question that what is on the minds of so
many reporters in that room is the very
latest on what is happening at the
kabbalah airport for the moment kimberly
halcott white house correspondent thanks
very much let's just bring you up to
speed on what we know so far uh and we
are getting a taliban source now saying
that as many as 11 people have been
killed at kabul airport including
foreigners and also suggested that
children may have also been injured
as kimberley also confirmed from us from
the u.s we're also getting the same from
the pentagon that three
u.s personnel have also been injured
in that blast which happened just over
an hour ago
the germans and the turks are saying
nothing has happened to them though they
were close or in the vicinity of the
blast they seem to be okay let's cross
over to charlie angela in our london
broadcast center obviously a very fast
moving story uh charlie as the sun sets
in afghanistan the turks and the germans
saying they're okay americans have three
injured the taliban now saying that as
many as 11 have been killed of course
many phone calls i'm sure going from
european capitals to the u.s and vice
versa
yes well the word here from the uk
defense ministry is that they're still
trying to establish exactly what has
happened whether or not it has affected
any of their personnel or the afghans
that they're trying to get out and
remember there's still a large number of
civil servants including the uk
ambassador to afghanistan inside the
perimeter of the airport still
processing
visa applications uh and they have said
that they will remain there until the
last minute we know that
the threat of these uh attacks which the
uk armed force minister was talking
about this morning um has brought
forward the evacuation flights and ended
the evacuation flights for many
countries the u.s had warned countries
to remove their military and embassy
personnel immediately they said that the
situation on the ground was
deteriorating rapidly we've now seen
evidence of that so we know that the
last flights for the netherlands poland
hungary canada belgium and denmark have
left they've wrapped up their evacuation
efforts
and denmark has it and so the dutch
government did admit that it's probably
left
some
afghans eligible for relocation behind
it just couldn't get them all on board
the canadian chief of defense staff also
said you know we left sooner than we
wanted to
we wanted to rescue more people we just
couldn't
germany is
wrapping up its flights
by the end of thursday france will
continue until friday